joining me today is the founder for axe
for America a New York Times bestselling
author and author of the new book rise
in defense of judeo-christian values and
freedom brigitte gabriel welcome back to
the reuben report thank you Dave I'm
delighted to be back with you I am
delighted that you're here first off
before we do anything else I was gonna
wear the exact same shirt I love this
shirt that's a really grand shirt that
is a girly girly shirt I love what's
going on here okay so I had you on about
maybe a year and a half ago or so you
are the only person in the history of
the Rubin report that you caused a tear
to formulate in my eye I think you know
exactly when it happened yeah
so before I even let you say anything
we're throwing for the clip we only take
care of freedom and preserve it to the
next generation and I am doing my part
as an American as a brave American and
the home of the brave to make sure I
follow in the footsteps of our founding
fathers and do my part as they entrusted
me with that which they have created I
feel it is my duty to make sure to
preserve it to pass it to my children
and their American children and many
generations to come that's why we fight
and I am so fortunate that through this
fight and it is a fight for freedom for
liberty for democracy for security for
human rights I am privileged to meet the
most amazing people that I would never
otherwise meet like sitting here with
you today and meet friends that have
become lifelong friends literally like
family to me that I would never have
otherwise met if it wasn't doing for
what I do so do I get depressed doing
what I do talking about terrorism and
national security of course I do
I'm human like everybody sometimes I cry
sometimes I'm completely depressed over
things that are happening sometimes I
hurt deeply by people who stab me in the
back or say bad things about me or even
reading my Wikipedia profile but what
keeps me so energized is the American
people and the American spirit knowing
that we are making a difference we are
growing we are
changing our country we are fighting we
have a purpose so when you and I die on
our deathbed we can look back and we can
say I made a difference as we take our
last breath and that's enough for me
that is how you end an interview I mean
that's it right there that was that was
like your opus right there well because
I spoke from the heart and when you
speak from the heart your message
resonates with people and this is
exactly why people like you and me are
having such traction with a lot of
people who are saying we love what
you're saying it's about time that
somebody will say the things that you
are saying our message is resonating and
you know why people want something
genuine and they can tell you know I
always tell my children the one thing
you can never fake love you can never
fake love because people can tell when
you're genuine and in a world that we
live in today where everything is fake
everything is about social media and how
things appear before the camera and and
and what's in it for me and I'm gonna be
your friend because I'm gonna get
something out of it when people like you
when I put our life on the line because
of the conviction that we have about the
truth that we are speaking and why we
are willing to go to great extent to
just fight for that truth it resonates
with people so I couldn't wait to be
with you today great what a team you're
back
do you always have this kind of passion
I mean when you were on last time we
told or you told your whole life story
which is absolutely fascinating if you
want to give me just like a two-minute
recap and we'll link to it down below so
people can watch the whole thing if they
have it so if you wanna give me a little
recap on that but I also want to know
where your that that smile that joy that
presents where does that come from
within you and did you always have that
I love life and I am so passionate about
life is because I lived from the age of
10 till the age of 20 waiting to die
every single day so every single day in
my formula t'v years when I open my eyes
and I saw sunshine outside I didn't know
if I'm gonna live to see the sunset so
living in a bomb shelter you know people
ask me where this passion comes from my
911 happened to me in nineteen
75 when radical Islam is to blow up my
home bringing it down burying me under
the rubble wounded I ended up in a
hospital for two and a half months and
later when I came back home my home was
no longer the home I left I ended up
living in this bomb shelter 8 by 10 room
underground no electricity no water and
very little food and that's where I
lived for seven years of my life robbed
of my youth barely interacting with
people barely interacting with people my
age I lived with my parents who were an
elderly couple in that bomb shelter so
all this cooped up passion now I thought
people I'm making up for last time so I
love life I'm so grateful for life I'm
so grateful for the people I meet the
places I go I never thought I'd live the
day beyond 20 and then I never thought
I'd live a day beyond 30 and Here I am
living life I just start 54 years old
I'm so proud to make it procedure it's
not learn thank you thank you when when
you have survived as long as I have
survived you brag about I made it to
this day
at this age so this is why I love life
so we're gonna link to your original sit
down and your whole story about growing
up in Lebanon and all that so people can
watch that if they haven't seen it but
not everybody likes you
and I remember before I had you on the
first time you know when people google
you and you even referenced this in that
clip but talking about it you know if
you check your Wikipedia sign people say
all sorts awful things about you and all
this and I was a little worried I was
like ah it's like I'm gonna have
Brigitte on and I'm gonna get hate for
it and all that now I'm really past that
part of life now I just want to do what
I think is right and I want to sit down
with with people like you and have those
conversations but are you shocked at the
kind of pushback you get for defending
the West and defending judeo-christian
values I am no longer shocked I was in
the beginning I was very hurt very
disappointed I thought my message of
course the West is gonna resonate it's
gonna resonate and the West people are
gonna appreciate why it's important to
fight for freedom of speech I was born
and raised in Lebanon in a country where
if you stay
up against the status quo and you speak
against the regime you are killed they
come take you in the middle of the night
kill you you'll disappear you'll never
hear from you again
I still have friends who disappeared
thirty years ago their parents don't
even know if they are alive or dead
journalist in my country of birth and
Lebanon get killed for writing the wrong
thing so when I came to the West and
when I started speaking in defense of
our freedoms and our values and our way
of life and the American values of you
know standing up for the truth and
speaking the truth without having to be
worried about somebody killing you I
could not believe people well will come
against me like that but you know what
if you don't stand for something yeah
you know you have to stand up for what
you believe those are the people that
make a difference and usually people
that make a difference in this world are
not popular the most hated people and
look at Churchill I mean you know when
he was alive you know people hated him
they thought oh my gosh you know look at
him today
people people call people that has
spoken such words of wisdom but people
laughed at them when they were saying
them and so here we are today we stand
up and we fight and it doesn't matter
what people say about me I do what I
believe is right because I believe we
are on a mission to save Western
civilization which is under attack right
now and I'm willing to do my part to
make it happen it's part of the problem
of the West now is that we don't have
enough stories like yours because we've
had it pretty good in the West for the
last you know 50 some-odd years
certainly in the United States we've had
a pretty good here so we've sort of
gotten fat and lazy on freedom we don't
know what we're fighting for we don't
know what are the generations before us
lived through you lived through
something so then you come here and then
you see all these people that are slowly
eroding their freedoms and you're like
whoa I know this is where this leads
exactly my past is America's future
unless America wakes up today see I am
the Anne Frank who lived to tell about
it can you imagine if Anne Frank was
alive and the Nazis were spreading
worldwide and she just escaped the
concentration camps and she came to the
United States and Nazism started rising
in the United States she
be saying the same words that she said
when she was alive and with my in my
case I started speaking after the
attacks on 9/11 on the United States I
started speaking about the threat of
radical Islam to world peace and our
national security but because Americans
had it so easy they cannot fathom that
some people can hate us so much
even though radical Islamic terrorists
hijacked airplanes and use them as human
missiles flying them into skyscrapers
with the intention of killing not 3,000
but maybe 50,000 that worked at that
building you know if they were late only
15 minutes they would have killed tens
of thousands of Americans and so this is
what I was talking about but Americans
are such good people people and those
who have never experienced the type of
terrorism that I lived under cannot
relate and think that somebody could be
that bad that actually that's the real
intention to kill as many people as
possible how do you wake people up to
that then because it's a really heart
because not everyone can have the lived
experience that you've had you don't
have to wake all the people up you just
have to wake some of the people up you
just have to wake up the passionate I
you know in my book cries I say 2% of
the passionates will always rule the 98%
indifferent it doesn't take money to
change the world 2% of the passionate
will always rule the 98% indifferent you
just need to get people who are fired up
for your cause you need to get people
who actually understand the problem and
get the problem and want to do something
to change the world those are the people
you need to rally around you those are
the people who are gonna make a
difference in this world and those are
the people that I that I try to
communicate with and because of that I
was able to build an organization act
for America I'm proud to tell you that
we are now over 1 million members of
Gruen million it's incredible we have
chapters nationwide we have passed bills
100 bills on the federal level as well
as the state level to protect America so
when people tell me don't you worry
about the names I mean people call your
names you know they they they would make
you look bad they you're on a list DSL
pcs PLC it's called me a white
supremacist
how do you like those white supremacist
lips and white supremacist skin and and
this white supremacist hair but I tell
people when people slap labels on you
it's because they cannot argue with your
facts that's why the only thing they can
do is call your names
they cannot debate you on the facts and
you know I tell people all the time
don't worry about the labels and don't
worry about the haters the New York
Times in my last book they must be
stopped the book came out in September
of 2008 the New York Times interviewed
me and they couldn't find one quote and
my article so what did they do they
titled the article radical islamaphobe
not just in the Slava film I am a
radical Islam of hope can you imagine if
I would have let that stop me because I
was hurt that somebody didn't like me
and they could be a radical Islam before
instead of hiding under a table you know
trying to kind of pad my emotions I went
there and continued doing exactly what I
do best
since 2008 till today my organization
has helped pass 100 bills and that's why
I tell people don't let the naysayers
and those to slap labels on you stop you
keep on moving forward what do you make
of these leftist organizations whether
it's SPLC or the ADL or now in the media
The New York Times that are actually
empowering the very ideologies that
would love to take away all of their
freedoms and in this way I mean it's
you've got this sort of you've got the
progressives basically in bed with the
Islamist and to me it's like they're
just sort of wilful idiots or there's
probably some other pejoratives I
couldn't exactly you know in my book
cries I have a whole chapter titled the
leftist Islamist coalition because
that's exactly what we are seeing right
now coming together the enemy of my
enemy is my friend so we are seeing two
people that do not agree with anything
that we say do not believe in America's
exceptionalism do not believe that
America should have strong borders do
not believe that we know that we need to
have a national identity we need I mean
securing our border meaning securing
protecting our national identity they do
not believe in borders they do not
believe in language they want to bring
America down to the part to the rest of
the world
America is equal with Venezuela no one
is better than anybody all societies are
created equal you and I that even though
people are created equal in the eyes of
God societies are not created equal and
so we are seeing right now is leftist
organizations working with the Islamists
so you've got organizations like the
ACLU the Southern Poverty Law Center
Planned Parenthood moveon.org working
with people like Linda Sarsour who is it
devout Islamist a proponent of Sharia
law and working with people like her or
with care coastal and American Islamic
relations the ACLU is basically the
legal arm of care the Council on
american-islamic relations so do you
think they realize what's going on here
this is the part that I'm always sort of
because I don't like impugning people's
motives right so it's like do they
realize that they're working with people
who once they have the power will gladly
cut them out right no they don't they
just don't they don't because people
that work for the ACLU people that work
for different leftist organizations have
good hearts they love America and they
cannot believe that people could be bad
or people couldn't use them for their
end goal you know when I talk about the
Muslim Brotherhood project and you and I
have talked about the Muslim Brotherhood
project people need to go watch that
interview a link to that with me
everybody watching us right now they
need to go back and watch that previous
interview the Muslim Brotherhood wrote a
plan a 100 year plan for radical Islam
to infiltrate and dominate the West and
establish an Islamic government on earth
what makes the plan so unique specially
the plan for the United States for the
destruction of America the last page of
the plan for America lists 29 front
Islamic organizations set up in the
United States with a specific purpose of
sabotaging America and destroying it
from within many of these organizations
that I mentioned is not Islamic Society
of North America the MSA Muslim Student
Association care which started as ia P
Islamic Association for Palestine later
became care because they wanted to
create another name the
the FBI was on their tail knowing that
they are Hamas front in the United
States those are the names mentioned so
what we're seeing right now is people
like the ACLU moveon.org the Southern
Poverty Law Center are basically used as
the useful idiots at the hands of an
Islamist with an agenda so while I am
very upset at how the ADL or the SPLC or
the ACLU is taking the side of Islamists
against people like me I'm not sure what
they say about you but I know they hate
my god yeah and so I see that and it's
it's sad to realize that their good
intentions are being used to do
something bad at the end but they don't
realize it at this point meanwhile
they're working with the Islamists
against people like me who basically are
trying to warn against the same people
are gonna destroy them at the end and
that's why I frame the question that way
because I don't like attacking people's
motives and I believe that if we were to
sit down with all of the people at the
ACLU that the vast majority of them are
totally doing all of these things for
what they believe to be the right
reasons the right three and yet they've
been just sort of tricked into having
some really unholy alliance well look
the Southern Poverty Law Center the same
thing they started as a good
organization fighting the Ku Klux Klan
doing something good that was their
result that they raised money they
fought the Ku Klux Klan and look the Ku
Klux Klan deserves to be in a halt
because we in America will never ever
tolerate such true hatred but for them
right now to slap the label hate on
anybody who speaks the truth or do not
agree with their point of view they
don't know what my heart is see I never
judge anybody's heart I am the same way
you never know people would ask me about
Barack Obama do you think he's a Muslim
you know I cannot judge anybody's heart
I don't know who he prays for I don't
know what's between him and he's God is
between him and his God that's what he
does and the privacy of his own home and
I will never judge where he stands and a
lot of people on the right didn't even
like me saying those words but that's
the truth I will never judge what's it
somebody's heart or what's in somebody's
mind I judge them by their actions so
now I'm
people slept labels on me oh she's a
hater you don't even know me you have
never even sat down with me and talked
with me how can you stop a label an
emotional label on somebody that you
don't even know if you're a hater you're
seriously much better actress than hater
because you got me for Lady III I'm
telling you I mean you know it is so sad
to see that coming from them and they're
not listening to whatever explanation or
even when we reach out to them they
don't want to talk to us they don't want
to hear our side of the view it's like
they judged us in absentia and that is
it you know speaking of judging in
absentia they are no better than the
terrorists in Lebanon you know I went to
Israel this year and visit with my
parents grave I don't know if you know
my parents are buried with Oskar
Shindler in Mount Zion yeah and so this
was the tell people how you ended up in
Israel after leaving Lebanon well I left
Lebanon I ended up moving to Israel
becoming a news anchor for world news
and working in Jerusalem and when my
parents died I wanted to make sure that
I buried them in Israel because I wanted
to make sure that my children yet unborn
will always know where my loyalty lies
and because I'm a firm believer that
actions speak louder than words so I
wanted to make sure I honor my parents
because I adore my parents this is a
very sensitive subject with me I'm an
only child I worship my parents I live
every single day of my life doing
everything I do to honor them and their
legacy and you know speaking of hatred
some former employer did me wrong when I
was 22 years old and I remember sitting
on my father's lap in his wheelchair
hugging him I was crying and I said Oh
daddy I just hate them I can't believe
they did this to us and my father said
to me he said I never ever want to hear
that word coming out of your mouth I
never raised you to hate and if for
nothing else because of the way I adore
my father at that day at 22 years old I
vowed I will never hate somebody my
father died like two weeks later I will
never ever allow hate to enter my heart
towards my enemies towards anybody I
don't hate anybody so when my parents
died
I burned them in in Jerusalem they are
buried with Oskar Shindler on Mount Zion
where actually later he was brought in
and buried next to them so this year I
went back to Lebanon to Israel and
because I cannot go to Lebanon Hezbollah
wants me dead so I go to Israel I visit
Israel I meet with the IDF I actually
was the first Lebanese person to ever
make it to the rooftop of the IDF
headquarters in Tel Aviv and I recorded
videos with the spokesperson of the IDF
and with the top generals we recorded
videos to be broadcast to the United
Nations to the international community
video to be broadcast to Lebanon about
how why we need to work together towards
peace why we need to love each other but
hey it aside forget what you're told
about the Jews Israel doesn't want
anything but peace with its neighbors
let's work together on peace and for
that Hezbollah aired that on Lebanese
television they charged me with treason
now I am wanted dead in Lebanon and
sentenced to death by hanging in
absentia so here we have a group of
terrorists and my home country of
Lebanon who judged me and Who I am and I
deserve to be sentenced to death by
hanging because they did not agree with
me preaching a message of love about
being friends with the Jews so here we
have them calling me haters yeah and yet
I have the leftist in America the
Southern Poverty Law Center and these
people calling me haters simply because
I'm warning about the Islamic terrorist
threat all right well you've got too
much good in you to focus on the haters
but I do have one other question about
the haters and then we're gonna just put
it behind us which is when Majin Waze
sued the Southern Poverty Law Center now
he's been removed from their anti Muslim
extremists list and you were on there
still as far as I know
Zion still on there actually that I am
still over there you know me on of
course are you kidding no Linda Sarsour
wants you yeah what once my private
parts remove miss woman's feminist
movement you know but the world is
turned upside down
so we are still on that list did you
consider a lawsuit or anything because
I'm not generally for lawsuits in these
cases but it magic proved that if
they've really
you and you can get the backing to get
the lawyers to do it that ultimately
justice does prevail we talk to our
attorneys to sue them and it's gonna
cost a lot of money and they can drag it
for years and years and years of got 90
and 90 attorneys on staff well we have
to depend on the generosity of attorneys
to do it pro bono they can't write it
forever
plus because I'm a public person and the
head of an organization that will get us
into discovery which means they not only
can't subpoena me which I don't say
anything bad I'm not worried but they
can go after my chapters and any
communications our chapters have done
with their friends now
our chapters are completely independent
their members are completely independent
I don't even know who they are
if somebody sent the personal email to a
third party mentioning any word about
hate which we are completely not
responsible for because they don't speak
about headquarters they can say see we
told you they've got people that take
and so because I do not know three four
levels down see nashit doesn't have a
National Organization definitely not
with chapters and members the way we do
so he's only responsible for what he
says I can fight and defend what I say
but I cannot fight and defend what
people that I don't even know look the
SPLC went after us and they said ah
we've got white supremacists you know
who show up to our rallies we have
brownies on the side street corner yeah
anybody can stand on the side street
corner you know you cannot say that
these members belong to my organization
yeah but they do and that's the tactic
of the left right now all right let's
focus on the book so the the subtitle is
in defense of judeo-christian values and
freedom so just most simply if someone
said to you what our judeo-christian
values what are they what are the most
fundamental judeo-christian values that
we need to know
well judeo-christian values are the
bedrock of Western civilization they are
the foundation of what we have today in
America and this is not a religious book
at all you read it you endorsed it it's
not a religious but got a little greater
well you got a little blurb in there
one of the most fundamental freedoms
I'll give you a perfect example freedom
of speech people don't realize where
that freedom comes from you know in
Israel the Hasidic Jews they debate the
Bible they 24 hours a day that's all
they do they debate the Bible and what
does that come from the Bible says come
let us reason together means let's
debate ideas I may not like your idea
you may not like mine and we can have
five other people who make look at the
same verse completely differently but
the reason why we debate ideas is
because we can learn from each other and
better understand what statements mean
we're the author who wrote that
statement meant by it we all know that
God didn't write the Bible people wrote
the Bible so part of our fundamental way
of thinking the freedom of speech the
ability to come together and debate
ideas and passionately debate these
ideas yet agree to respectfully disagree
and walk away people don't realize that
comes from the foundation of
judeo-christian foundation you know even
people who are not religious understand
that's so uniquely Western you know they
don't do that in an in the Islamic world
for example you don't debate ideas why
because in the Quran the Quran was
written it's the Word of God it's not
debatable it's not negotiable you cannot
look back you cannot change verses and
you don't even talk about it you cannot
even question it very different than the
way we are so when I write in the book
about and I actually I have a chapter
titled the death of free speech where I
talk about how we are losing our ability
to speak the truth because then your
label your bigoted people are afraid am
I gonna be you know blackmailed am I
gonna be boycotted am I gonna lose my
job
and so we're silencing ourselves and
that's why I titled the book rise rise
in defense of judeo-christian values and
freedom because we're losing those
freedoms those American values before
our very eyes are you watching this chip
away more in Europe than in the United
States right now for all our problems
around this and I agree it the bigger
problem right now is that we're
silencing ourselves rather than the
government coming to silence us although
that could potentially be a problem in
the future I don't sense it's a huge
problem right now
Europe has a whole other set of problems
around free speech do you think that
they're more suited to lose faster
because they don't have a first
amendment the way we do oh yeah there
are far more advanced than losing their
rights and their freedoms than we are
and they did it by self-censorship you
know I landed in London I was speaking
in London in 2007 so I land in London
I'm standing there waiting for my
luggage with the pilot and the hostesses
we were in a private section and they
said Oh what are you doing here and I
said oh I'm just here for like three
days I'm giving the speech in Parliament
I was speaking to the British Parliament
and they said are you gonna be talking
about and I said the threat of radical
Islam to world peace and national
security and all of a sudden silence for
30 seconds you could hear a pin drop
they didn't know how to react or what to
say they were so afraid to react plus
somebody hears something the taxi driver
my driver picked me up to drive me to my
hotel and we were talking in the car and
I told him ask me again what are you
doing here and I said the same thing he
said Bridget in ten years I believe
we're gonna have blood on the streets of
London by radical Islamists we are at
war and it didn't even take ten years
within five years we already started
seeing stabbing on the streets of London
and stuff like that so in Europe they
are afraid to talk about it and they do
not have the freedom of speech that we
have and that's why it is so important
to defend the freedom of speech that we
have and God bless them our founding
fathers with their wisdom they knew
exactly what they were doing I mean look
remember they came from Europe so when
they wrote us what they gave us the
Constitution and our Bill of Rights and
all of that stuff they knew exactly why
they put some of these amendments in
there so all right so let's just put
Europe aside since we're in the United
States they're gonna have to deal with
that we'll deal with it here okay we can
get people to rise but what else do we
have to do to have a discussion about
this that's going to stop the people
that are gonna use all of those labels
so I know even in the book you make a
point of saying of course this is not
all Muslims and don't be bigoted towards
Muslim people we're talking about an
ideology a lot of people have been doing
for the last couple years tried to
separate people from ideas and all that
and still get all the labels thrown at
them what are some of the other
techniques we can use to talk about
these things and not be crushed by by
all the labels don't waste your breath
because there is nothing you can say at
this point no matter what you say the
enemy the SPLC the ADL moveon.org
organizing for action all the
progressive organizations they're not
willing to listen to you they don't want
to listen to you
look we organized march against Sharia
March for Human Rights
last year a year and a half ago and we
had rallies in 29 cities in 21 states
and we timed it with the poles nightclub
bombing in Florida because it was June
10th we wanted to shine a light about
the hatred of this ideology against gays
what they do to gays I mean look at the
post nightclub bombing the the people
that organized our rallies in New York
it was organized and headed by two gay
guys the rally in Atlanta was headed by
a Muslim man they had an imam speaking
in seattle we had Meriam Ibrahim the so
then his survivors speak at our rally in
Virginia Beach as well as an Iranian
Muslim leader of the Iranian movement
you know to to to to move away from the
mullahs yeah did you think any of the
media covered any of that all they did
is show up on the street corner say no
hate say no - I hate say no to hate they
didn't even bother yeah
understand what we were doing so don't
waste your breath right now people tell
me why are you speaking to the choir
Bridgette we need to talk to other
people at this time you need to mobilize
the choir because when you need your
house cleaned it is the choir that shows
up it is the choir that brings you food
when you're sick it is the choir that
maps the church or the temple when it
needs cleaning it's the choir that
brings the flowers and that's all that
matters to keep your house up and keep
it protected and that's why right now
don't waste your breath on the labels
make sure you fight make sure your Lobby
your electro fischels make sure you
understand the power of the gavel why it
is important to call your electro
fischels you know in my book what makes
this book so unique is at the end of
every chapter I have a section titled
rise up and act where I get people ideas
so I want to do all that at the end
want all your I want all of your
absolute advice on this but but you hit
on something that I think is really
interesting there how there's a
connection to all of this and the way
the media reports yeah you're right that
when they cover your events or when they
cover a lot of the the people that
friends with that I have on the show
whatever they say it's like they only
focus on the haters they only focus on
that the one little outsider that's
that's doing something that's bad and
not on all the good how how do you think
this happened to the media or is there a
way that it can be fixed or does it need
to burn to the ground or what because
the progressive media is not interested
in dialogue they are interested in
winning see we on the conservative side
you know and it's such a shame I never
thought of myself as a conservative I
mean I don't know if I voted for Al Gore
I was a proud Democrat you know I'm a
9/11 you know conservative as they call
as conservative but this is where we are
in our nation right now they consider
people like you conservative because you
speak about you know important issues
that are now known as oh that's what the
Conservatives talk about you know so
what we are seeing right now is the
media is interested in winning well we
are interested in having a dialogue how
can we get through to them how can we
speak with them you know and find the
bridge where we can talk to them about
that they're not interested in talking
to us they're interesting in silencing
our voices and the sooner we know that
the better we are in fighting our battle
and learning how to win our battle and
you add to that funders like Soros you
know in my book I have a whole section
about Soros and him funding the media
Soros right now has spent doesn't that
make you an anti-semite if you talk
about Soros that's their new meme I
didn't even know he was Jewish sure I'm
tell about a year ago right and
everything that he does is usually
against Israel exactly the height of
stupidity I mean yeah you would think he
sounds and talks like an anti-semite
that's more than me remember he is the
one who worked with the doctors with the
Nazis oh no no no and actually had a
smile when people asked them how did you
feel about going in and working with the
Nazis against your own people he said
well you know somebody had to do it so I
know I
see any problem with it you know yeah
you're not making that up either no no I
mean I watched his interview because I
was very interested on what makes this
man the way he is I study my enemies I
spend a lot of hours actually studying
my enemies to understand how they think
why why do they behave you know trying
to pick up on cues so you look at
somebody like George Soros who is
interested in transforming America into
his vision of how the world should be
and he has the billions and he's willing
to spend that 43 billion has already
been spent on the media on Soros funded
media entities from since 2002 and so
when you look today at sources tentacles
that extend to 33 media outlets
including ABC NBC CBS MSNBC The
Washington Post Associated Press which I
detail in my book even though they to
give you an example which I talk in the
book Columbia School of Journalism gave
them $600,000 to there journalism school
because he wanted to impact their
reporting on how reporters report on the
media issues in the future so nobody was
paying attention to this stuff but this
is exactly how we end up with reporters
who are no longer reporters they are
activists with the national platform
media platform who get on television
every night and basically spew the same
talking political points approved by
syrups and they all say the same thing
whether it's a Huffington Post the New
York Times The Associated Press Reuters
MSNBC CNBC ABC the same buzzword and
it's all coordinated how concerned are
you that on the social media front where
people like you have been able to make
gains you know I'll see every now and
again you'll talk about oh I just
suddenly lost 5,000 followers on Twitter
or something like that that we're
fighting a losing battle on that front
ultimately because these companies a I
think there are a lot of political
connections and who knows what's going
on behind the scenes but B they've
basically embraced the the leftist
ideology and they're not really around
to make sure that Brigitte Gabriel voice
can be heard
well we lose followers by the tens of
thousands tens of thousands and we are
seeing that happen especially now at a
dramatic pace but you continue
on doing what you are doing there's
nothing you can do to change it you just
continue pushing we are working with
members of Congress to make sure that
there's fairness in reporting and that
the government will intervene to make
sure that we don't have a monopoly look
they did the same thing with Mike
results remember Microsoft had a
monopoly the government had to intervene
and they said no you cannot stop anybody
else wants to develop computers Apple
didn't have a chance if the government
didn't intervene with Microsoft so we
know that there is precedent but here is
the solve elves my libertarian brain all
the bells go off on that stuff though
because I don't want the government to
do it it's like for me it's like be last
resort even though I know that this is
obviously a very personal issue to me as
someone that puts this up on YouTube and
the rest better we want fairness we're
not telling them silence anybody but we
are saying to them allow people to speak
their mind you know if I owned a media
platform and I do not agree with you at
all in what you say as an American I
will bite my tongue and grit my teeth
and listen to what I absolutely
passionately opposed I'm not saying you
but anybody you know you could be saying
you know we're whoever but I will fight
for your right to do it I will not
silence you because it is unamerican to
silence you so as Americans we owe it to
each other at least to defend these
rights so we can prove so we can pass
them out our future generations you
never really own freedom David we only
preserve it for the future generation
and I said that statement with you
before and I actually have it going all
throughout my book these are the rights
that our founding fathers gave
everything and most of them died broke
to give us these rights that we have
today the least we can do is preserve it
for the next generation
that's all we're asking for but you know
the secret to success regardless of how
much the the social media puts you on
Facebook jail or Twitter bans your share
of any etc tenacity tenacity tenacity
you keep on pushing you keep on pushing
you keep on pushing and you never ever
ever give up that is the secret to
success
I appreciate we've talked for about 35
minutes we have not said the two words
Donald Trump first off I think we just
had a record
35 minutes of conversation without
problem once okay you are a trump
supporter I'm a trumpet ear you're a
trumpet ear I think you've met with the
president right yes
how does well what can you tell me
something about him maybe that the
average person doesn't know or that you
might not get through the filter of CNN
or that you maybe don't even get through
the filter of Twitter he is somebody he
is a billionaire who left the life of
luxury to serve the American people
he is somebody who is not doing it for
power he already had power he's not
doing it for fame he already had Fame
he's not doing it for the money he
already had money he doesn't care he
wakes up every morning to all the
insults and the hate and images of
beheading by Cathy Griffiths that his
son can watch and be mortified that
somebody actually really killed my dad
and then he remembers I'm not doing this
to please the media I'm doing it because
I'm fighting for the American people
they hate him not because they hate him
because he is serving the American
people he is putting America first and
they do not know how to handle him and
that's why Donald Trump is resonating
with a lot of people in this country
from CEOs of companies the janitors
working for $10 an hour because from the
janitor to the CEO they know and
everybody in between president Donald
Trump is working for me and it's a
breath of fresh air because for decades
now we have had many presidents on the
right and the left not many people could
say Barack Obama is working for me
or George Bush is working for me or
Clinton is working for me but with
Donald Trump that janitor knows
President Donald Trump is working for me
and that's why he's resonating with the
people so when you see the the tweets
and some of the over-the-top stuff you
know every now and again I'll watch some
old clips from him in the 80s talking to
Oprah or Phil Donahue and he's he's soft
and and seemingly you know very pleasant
and
open and you can see the way in Q&A is
with audience members I think on Donahue
he's extremely human all of these things
and it's not exactly the caricature that
we get these days do you think that he
sort of became this thing because it was
the only he basically was the it was the
only way he would have been hard enough
to break through does that make sense
like I think he was probably extremely
similar to the person from back then but
he became hardened because it was the
only way you were gonna ever break
through this like no one else was ever
gonna break through this thing if you
listen to a very confident but you know
what I got the point
if you Donald Trump today is the exact
same person he was 25 years ago when he
wasn't Phil Donahue when he wasn't Oprah
he still says the exact same words have
you noticed well the theme is the same
but he's he's hardened now there's like
and I don't I'm not even blaming him for
that I think to go through this to go
through the media machine and the
establishment and all that you you've
got to get hardened otherwise it will
choke everybody out which is these
fights to win before they didn't argue
with what he said so you didn't see that
side of him he would have been just as
hard back then today they do not want to
listen to any words he says if he became
Jesus they would find the reason to
fight against him they would call him
you know evil hater monster whatever
whatever whatever so the reason why they
call him all the names that they call
him now is because he is not toeing the
line to them look he has 90 million
followers on Twitter he goes straight
around the media he doesn't need the
media he is communicating directly with
the American people and the media hates
this and he is somebody who fights the
breath I love his tweets by the way you
know I know it makes a lot of people
uncomfortable oh my god I cannot believe
he tweeted that you know what we finally
have a man who stands up to the bullies
and punches back we are so used to men
who are wusses in this country we have
forgotten what it's like to see a real
man who stands up and says I respect
myself too much to let you walk all over
me or call me that or treat me that way
but if you treat me that way I'm gonna
punch you back now stand up like a man
and fight me we forgot
how a man like that looks like and so
Donald Trump is shocking the system at a
time where men have been stripped out of
their manhood they you know the society
is changing you know roles are changing
so in our society today they want the
man that they can walk all over and you
know they say oh we need somebody who is
nice and you know like Romney or like
McCain you know everybody loved McCain
until he ran for president then they did
the same thing to him everybody loved
Romney and thought he ran for president
they did the same thing to him I mean if
you would hear CNN talk about Romney or
McCain when they were running for
president yeah they were saying the same
thing he hated women all of those things
so I'm completely with you on that part
and that's what I mean by the the
hardening of Trump that he almost had to
be this thing because nobody else could
have they tried it the other way they
tried it with night you know nicer
people so to speak yeah and it just
doesn't work so it's like well this is
this is the guy you're gonna get and
he's getting things done and the
American people are behind him and he is
resonating with the American people and
if his message wasn't resonating he
wouldn't have the tens of millions of
followers who are following him on
social media and still rooting for him
and the Donald Trump supporters dig
their Hill even deeper with all the
attacks from the media with even the
attacks from his own party Dave I mean
look you and I know there are people who
hate his guts on Washington DC you talk
about cleaning the swamp he is shaking
everybody the left and the right despite
all that his support his approval rating
is that an all-time high you know so it
doesn't matter what people are saying to
him he is doing what is right by the
American people by America so what are
some of the policies that he's doing
that that jive with this book like in
terms of borders and stuff like that
you're you're for building the wall
absolutely yeah absolutely and here is
why I am illegal immigrant to the United
States I understand what it's like for
people to want to come here I wanted to
come here so badly
I remember getting an American flag
putting it under my pillow and my bomb
shelter and I couldn't wait to come to
America I learned English I don't know
if I shared with you this with you last
time
subtitles on my arm did I tell you
that's how I learned English I never
studied English at school I was so
determined to come to the United States
that we would watch black-and-white
television operated on a car battery in
our bomb shelter and my father would
watch the news and if there was any
charge of the battery left
I would watch The Love Boat on Wednesday
night and Dallas on Friday night and you
know we would have every diet for
America that's what impacted my life and
and if two people looked into each
other's eyes and you know he said
something to her and she said maybe and
they would write what maybe were met on
the bottom I knew that maybe meant
whatever that word in Arabic and I would
literally write it in ink on my arm and
because we barely had water to drink let
alone shower we showered once a week I
felt the huge vocabulary on my arm
that's how I learned English because I
was so determined that if I ever meet an
American I want to be able to be able to
communicate with them in their language
so I can get to the United States and
when I came to the United States
I came to America by marriage I had
married an American a war correspondent
in Jerusalem we came to America we put
in my papers to become an American I
flew here I paid for my airline ticket
paid for my attorneys to do all my
paperwork paid for my doctor's visit to
do all the needle poking to make sure
I'm tested for this disease and that
disease to make sure I'm not bringing
anything to the country
and then I had to study a two-inch thick
book written by the Daughters of the
American Revolution about America's
history and heritage and pass a written
exam as well as a verbal exam in English
before I became an American about
America's history by the time I became
an American I knew more about America's
history than my own american-born
husband did I am a legal immigrant those
are the type of immigrants we need
coming to America because we had a fire
in our belly to be all we can be as
Americans right now the people who are
breaking the law to get here not because
they want to come here for a better life
or they are escaping persecution look at
the caravan that's coming to the United
States Mexico offered them asylum Mexico
offered them jobs they didn't
on it they're not there to seek jobs or
asylum they you and they passed
literally by UN centers set up
specifically for those who want asylum
and claiming refugee status they didn't
even stop continued coming to the United
States to the border and not even to the
bar port of entry just to break the lot
to get here we have to have law and
order in the country so yes I support
Donald Trump build the wall and make
sure anybody who wants to come to the
United States can go through the proper
channel and earn the privilege to be an
American because it is a privilege
because people like me who did it by the
book are insulted and offended when we
see criminals are allowed to come in
here and have the same rights that we
paid with our sweat heart and blood to
get and work very hard for years to
become Americans yeah that's so
fascinating to me because they've also
done plenty of studies on this where
recent immigrants are actually against
the caravan and against well not because
they have anything against the people
but if you did it the right way right if
you did it the way the law lays out well
then you don't want people just just
storming over and that's that is what a
nation of laws is right and you know
when you look at what the legal
immigration is costing the United States
do you know that forty five billion
dollars a year
leaves America from those illegal aliens
that come here to work in the United
States that legal criminal aliens and
they sent it to their countries of
origin that money is not staying here
they're not here to become a part of the
American fabric to contribute to
American society to grow to become all
they can be they are here to use our
system and siphon money and send it out
there do you know that it costs the
American public two hundred billion
dollars a year in welfare expenses by
criminal illegal aliens to the United
States three million illegal aliens are
incarcerated daily in American prisons
thirty percent of federal inmates and
federal prisons are illegal criminal
aliens so when you look at the cost when
you add all the costs and I can rattle
in a bunch of points but when you add it
all up three hundred and thirty eight
billion dollars a year is the cost of
illegal immigration to the United States
the cost bill the wall is nothing
compared to what we're paying annually
and a left illegal criminal aliens not
to mention the crimes coming our
children ms-13 gang coming here and what
they're doing to our society we don't
want any of that what are you making the
same people who will tell you that
America is an evil patriarchal
capitalistic monster that also want open
borders to apparently share in that
horror with everybody else America
pretty flood thinking there would yeah
absolutely America is the most
incredible nation on the face of the
planet
look you traveled the world you're
traveling on a speaking tour I was born
and raised on the other side of the
world I understand I've seen you and I
have traveled the world I mean from
Australia to Europe I mean we've been in
a lot of places you and I and we have
seen how the other the rest of the world
lives compared to the rights that we
have here
look our poorest of the poor who are
living on welfare have dishwashers in
their government paid housing have
heating and air-conditioning have
cellphones you know these are luxury
items for and many other places in the
rest of the world even in developed
country they are considered luxury items
this is what we give to people who are
living on welfare in the United States
so those who complain about America need
to open their eyes they need to go to
India you know to the slums of India
they need to visit the Philippines they
need to go to Vietnam they need to go to
Egypt they need to see how the rest of
the world lives and then come back to
American complain isn't it just a lazy
way of thinking really because it's just
easier to destroy them create so it's
just easier to sit here after all of the
hard-won freedoms and tell you how
horrible everything is rather than
actually fix anything but burning things
down is a lot easier right exactly
exactly and they and but no one's
holding them accountable you see people
like us and the old great generation who
really fought World War two who are the
veterans are still walking among us
today who fought you know in the wards
whether in Korea or in Vietnam when
World War two I mean now they're getting
older and fewer and dying but they're
descendants so understand what America
did to the world and the freedoms that
we helped
around the world look we didn't want
anything from the Japan
you know we conquered nation and then we
gave them their freedom and then rebuilt
them who does that we didn't go to Iraq
because we wanted oil we didn't go to
Afghanistan because we wanted the oil we
went there and started building schools
and bridges for them to improve their
lives and left them didn't take any of
the oil with us we want to improve the
world and we need to fight right now
those lazy American brats who are
speaking ELLs of America who I do not
understand America we need to come
together organize and rise rise together
in defense of America and that's why we
need to come together and understand
what we are facing how we are losing our
country and this is what I get to in the
book you know I say how did we go from
the stories of George Washington and the
cherry tree I shall never tell a lie how
did we go from that generation to the
antifa thug so we're born and raised in
America went to American schools paid
for by our tax dollars who believe you
can cheat you can lie you can steal you
can show up with machetes you and and
brass knuckles you can hit people
you can block bridges you can destroy
property and you feel justified doing it
how did we go in one generation and one
lifetime from this to that and that's
why we need to stand up those of us who
are in the middle who understand America
greatness need to come together and
stand up to fight to protect America
while we still have a chance so what are
the other judeo-christian values that we
need to be thinking about we talked
about free speech what are the other
bedrock principles that we need to fight
back some of this stuff oh my goodness
we need to fight to protect our language
yeah I explained something very easy to
you you we cannot lose our language
language unites people in one nation the
English language right now we are
importing people from different parts of
the world and we are not making them
learn English we now have public schools
that have 16 different languages that
are spoken in a public school and
teachers who have to be trained to speak
a certain language to children instead
of saying ok now you came to America you
to assimilate you need to learn English
I know Spanish people who have been in
this country Mexican people for over 20
years they still cannot speak English
properly or they speak very little
English that's not acceptable
not what made America great we have got
to enforce that English is the official
language of the United States and shall
remain so we welcome people from all
backgrounds the immigrants that came to
this country back the Jews that came
from all over the world the Irish the
Catholics the everybody they came to the
United States they made sure their
children spoke English because they
wanted their kids to become as American
as apple pie as fast as possible to
assimilate into this society we're not
seeing that right now we are seeing in
Detroit you call government office
you're getting in Arabic you know and
then you push like for for ingress but
first you get Arabic and then you get
Spanish and then you get this and this
and that
that's unacceptable and people need to
understand their power and my book at
the end of every chapter I have a
section titled rise up and act no matter
what I'm talking about I give people
ideas and tips three things you can do
under 10 minutes that will make a
difference for the country and you can
do them sipping your cup of coffee and
your pajamas at 7:00 a.m. in the morning
to give you an idea calling your elected
official many people say Bridget what is
my voice can account my elected official
needs to hear from 40,000 people before
they do something wrong I talk to
elected officials all the time and I ask
them how many people do you need to hear
from about a single issue to make it
your top priority you'll be shocked how
many do you think I mean it's got to be
so ridiculously low because nobody calls
them and we all think it's 40,000 but
it's probably like 50 people or
something that's it 40 to 50 people and
here is the science behind the numbers
they believe if one person makes a phone
call or writes a letter he or she are
representing 1000 couch potatoes who
feel the same way but are too lazy to
make a phone call or write a letter yet
they vote on Election Day that
translates to 40 to 50,000 voters on
Election Day that can make or break an
election so I tell people you can be
active sitting in traffic look we are in
LA how many hours people spend sitting
in traffic I spent two and a half hours
yesterday sitting in traffic trying to
go 50 miles program the White House
phone number program your elected
officials phone number in your in your
cellphone when you get a text alert from
us about a bill coming down for a vote
punch a button click and call your
elected officials or send an email when
people go to act for america.org which I
mentioned all throughout the book my
organization act for america.org they
can click on contact Congress they can
sign up to get our emails and action
alerts we send emails about bills coming
down for a vote the bill number who
sponsors it where it says we even have
pre-written letters for them that they
can email their Elektra fischels with
the click of a button it will go to your
elected official letters to the editors
script I give samples in this book the
last chapter the whole chapter is
samples about activism samples what
letters to the editor all you have to do
is add your name and send it to your
newspaper it's part of the problem that
we put so much emphasis on the
presidency so it's great you're doing
local activism you're saying call your
congressmen if you've got a problem with
your exit my exit right here where I
live I don't wanna say exactly where
it's filled with garbage for the two
years that I've been living here David's
been calling this guy non-stop to get
that he wants to go out there and start
picking up stuff but it's too dangerous
but it's just but like nobody focuses on
local anymore because we put such
emphasis on the executive branch on the
cult of personality around the
presidency so it's like by going to your
local congressman or congresswoman you
might actually get something done it's a
lot harder to do it the other way
absolutely and and on the local sit
elected officials you know your local
state and delegates I may have you call
the guy ten to twelve people that's it
and so this is why we started chapters
nationwide this is why we have activists
nationwide I tell people go to act for
america.org sign up as an activist join
a chapter or start a chapter if there's
no chapter near you everything happens
on a local level because those local
elected officials that you develop a
connection with in a contact go to
become state elected officials then
federal elected officials Attorney
General's and then state Senators
Congressmen this is how we change
society and so I encourage people to get
involved and become engaged and that's
exactly what this this book is a roadmap
for people on how to rise rise this is
right we title that
we will need to get this book and they
need to donate it to every library in
their community so when people are
looking to find out information they can
find it read it for yourself donate it
to a public library in your community
get multiple copies we want people to
learn how they can be mobilized the left
understands how to mobilize we on the
right understand the issues but do not
know how to mobilize and that's what
this book teaches them so what what else
what else can we do I feel like he got a
couple other tricks up your sleeve oh
absolutely
give me something sexy you can't just be
calling your Congressman make new
friends if find out start a chapter
you'll get to meet great new friends in
your community if people sign up to be a
chapter leader with us we will connect
them with the same group in their local
community who sign up to get our emails
and they say I want to join a chapter I
want to meet people in my community like
this we connect them together they can
do local activities together they can go
out to dinners together they can work on
issues relating to their community I
have found I have made the best friends
doing my activism that's what launched
my career in activism so this is the
type of ideas that people can do come
together and work together have already
Saturday one Saturday
have a meeting a chapter meeting once a
month write letters to your Congressman
about the garbage on the side of the
street you know we need to clean this
garbage out this is unacceptable
protest builds that are coming down I'll
give you an idea we're accepting all
these refugees coming in here so right
now we are bringing our standards down
to accommodate the standards of people
from third-world country to be an
example the city of Denver in 2017
passed an ordinance that allowed people
to defecate on the sidewalk why because
they have a lot of illegal immigrants
who feel no problem to just drop their
pants and do it on the side of the road
but because it is a deportable crime
because that crime is punishable up to
one year in jail and if you commit such
a crime you are deported the city of
Denver has a bigger problem with illegal
immigration then San Francisco and
Philadelphia so that's why they passed
the ordinance they do not want people
deported can you imagine if you have a
chapter with 30
people all 30 people Argan izing
together on the same issue calling your
their local state government saying this
is unacceptable and if you don't change
that we're gonna vote you out and
replace you that's how the left does it
that's how we need to do it that's a
pretty clear one where you could
probably escape some of the cries of
racism right because nobody wants their
streets filled up with poopit you know
San Francisco has this app that'll tell
you where human poop is unbelievable and
now the diseases that are spreading
because of that and this is something I
mentioned in the book all the rise in
diseases in our country look you know
you've heard Lube right now but the Lyme
disease or that disease that's not being
friend transferred to people because in
San Francisco
you've got flies basically eating the
human waste and then you're walking down
the street and they're biting you
so mosquitos now are transferring these
diseases that were once eliminated in
the United States by simply eating human
waste and then biting you with it
putting it in your body this is exactly
why about a month ago we started seeing
you know this disease pop up people
cannot explain it some people died
tuberculosis for example is exploding in
the United States the top four states
with tuberculosis are California over
500 cases Florida Texas and New York 16
states are now grappling with
tuberculosis it is the fastest growing
disease in America right now they have
the state of Wisconsin alone has a
hundred and sixteen cases of
tuberculosis and the majority of them
are drug-resistant which means it takes
six months to treat a patient and it
takes six to eight months to treat them
at the cost of a hundred and fifty
thousand dollars per patient out of our
tax dollars these are issues we need to
talk about these are issues affecting
our communities and that's what I where
I discuss in the book so it's not only
about national security per se it's why
we need to rise in defense of our
culture and our freedoms and what made
America great do you find that the
people that are part of act are diverse
politically because it's so it's
interesting I mean I've spent hours with
you now and it's like I guess you're a
conservative but you're not you're sort
of my kind of conservative your husband
friend right but you're really you're
like my kind of liberal which which you
know is half conservative at this point
because everything is so upside down but
do you find that you get a real mix of
political views in the people that are
coming to you oh my gosh
absolutely look with our organizations I
mean we have everybody people that put
their differences aside and came
together for the safety and security of
America and preserving who we are as
Americans and defending our American
values
our members are Jews Christians
Buddhists Hindus atheist gays lesbians I
mean I've got gay chapter leaders
priests chapter leaders we've got
everybody people like you and I and
everybody else that put yeah you know
people may not agree on every single
social issues but people agree on a lot
of things that make us Americans because
we love each other as Americans we
respect each other as Americans and we
want to defend our country and the
principles that made it great and so
that's why we work together and it's
like I said it's such a shame that no
people you know say I never thought I
would be you know I would be called a
conservative or you would be called a
conservative but you know what as far as
the left is concerned right now you and
I are conservatives yeah that doesn't
matter that you are a married gay man
yeah you're a conservative welcome to
the new conservatism and you know this
is why what Donald Trump talks about
nationalism we are a nationalist country
we are we are standing up as a nation to
fight what makes America great patriotic
America you know the patriotism that we
have in America they don't have in other
countries of the world you go to
Australia you don't see the Australian
flag flying everywhere you go to England
you don't see that in British flag
finally notice that when I was in here
now that you're travelling worldwide
what makes America so unique is this
nationalism that brings us all together
our love for country people go to
baseball to games and we play the
national anthem you know they don't do
that in other parts of the world they
don't play that I should anthem
Gamze we take it for granted and know
everybody's upset with the president
because he's talking about American
nationalism what brings us together they
need to travel to Australia go to Canada
go to Germany attend a a a football
thing they don't play the national
anthem it's not like the United States
that's what he was referring to we're
talking about our nationalism what
brings us together as Americans our
Americanism he could have used a
different word Americanism so the word
so the left would not feel offended but
that's what he was talking about pretty
sure they would have offended either way
they would have been offended either way
I feel I should give you the chance to
close this with a speech as epic as your
last though you've got about five of
them here in the last hour but you want
to give me a closing statement that will
be me mobile footprints and history are
not made sitting down countries cannot
be saved by hashtags and tweets we need
to stand up and put some sweat equity
into saving our country but thankfully
we don't have to freeze and Valley Forge
like our founding fathers in the snow
waiting to see if we still have a
country the next day what we can do
right now with our activism is come
together and get together at a coffee
shop sipping our cappuccinos meeting
like-minded great American soul of
America who believe in America's
exceptionalism who believe in safe
secure border who believe in having law
and order in our country who believe in
respecting our police who believe in
honoring our military who believe in
cherishing the memories and and and and
acknowledging the freedom that we have
and the sacrifices that our military
have paid to give us the freedoms that
we have today you know when we visit
other countries and you have visited
France and you go to Normandy and you
see that graves of Americans in Normandy
you sit back and you know that these
American brave soldiers left their home
and went overseas laying their life on
the line to fight for freedom
and for justice and for the American
values if you don't want to call them
judeo-christian values American values
so the rest of the world
experience the freedom that we have the
previous generation was willing to cross
oceans and go die over there to protect
the same freedoms that we have here at
home and give them to other people the
least we can do is activate here in our
home in the United States of America and
come together and stand together and
face those naysayers and those who slap
labels on us at least they're not
shooting bullets at us all they all
they're saying is ah he's a racist or
she's a racist or she's a white
supremacist but we can come together to
save our country together and that's the
beauty it's people like you and I coming
together and looking into each other's
eyes and really being so excited to see
each other again and be together again
as Americans as different as we are but
we come together and we love each other
and respect what each other does to save
this country and that's what America is
all about I encourage people to rise
rise in defense of judeo-christian
values and freedom get the book read it
share it with their friends get multiple
copies put them in public libraries we
need to educate and go to act for
America that on and by the way we named
the organization act for America now
think about America now wish for America
not pray for America you can do all that
but without acting nothing happens you
are the real deal Brigitte who are the
racist bigot of the day that I will
gladly be thrown in that bucket with you
you in case people don't know guys the
link to rise is right down below and buy
it and put it in libraries and all that
to help us for more regime you can
follow her on Twitter it's act Bridget
[Music]